okay guys he's number six so two pots
just like the one we had them look at
and when we have a look at the well
actually when we step back and have make
the whole question there will be a third
thing that I wanted in order to
introduce Oh one two three items just
like Ian's now for a second I promised
you some time to like catch up finishing
your question about but I want you to
notice with me how this question is
similar and how it is different okay
firstly the big sort of glaring
similarity between this question and the
one you just did is they're both dealing
with these guys right cube roots are
indeed they happen quite a lot the
square roots are a little bit boring you
guys have been doing squares I just okay
the cube roots away Oh like this is not
a real a result see that are important
okay so then change D is there in that
rather than designated 1 W 2 W sorry 1 W
1 W 2 they have said well W is one of
the roots it's just one of the non real
ones they don't tell you which one then
they want you to prove these guys which
means remember they told you they'd
rather they didn't tell you which of the
written was you know how you've got one
we said is close to point three plus I
sine 2 pi 3 and all the four point three
this means that both of these statements
should be true of both of those roots so
let's find out why
okay do you recall if W is a cube root
that means it satisfies a particular
polynomial that has to do with cubic
what's the polynomial don't we cubed by
definition that's what cube roots are
supposed to do right so far so good
okay yeah I know this is true this is
kind of all I know at the moment so how
am I going to get to something like this
like where on earth does this sneak out
from it's a bit strange there aren't
even any cubes in it okay now I want you
to stare higher and I want you to think
about what you see if I can give you a
nudge in the right direction I mentioned
this before is the same polynomial is it
not okay how could you twist and turn
that thing
to get something like that you know
what's it yeah okay
I can use my results we'll factorizing
the difference of cubes do you see that
that's a team and result okay now um I
suggested we take out the W minus one
what does that leave you with Oh
surprise surprise it leaves you with
that guy
how convenient okay so I see the thing
that I want has appeared okay but now
the question becomes well how am I gonna
breach fruit from that which is better
to what I want I saw how I wanna say
that this thing this thing is zero how I
know that that is your yeah okay so just
just rewind a little bit right you don't
do right this but what we factorize
right if you factorize any polynomial
you like right the point of factorizing
and writing this thing to replace it is
that for the top line to be true that
means that this must be zero or this
must be zero or both have to be zero do
you agree because something times
something is here right so when you come
over here you're like oh well one of
these guys has to be zero if you're
going to multiply to give zero but we
know it's not real so this can't be zero
do you agree that so I'm actually gonna
say that right I'm gonna say but W can't
equal one as W is non real right you see
how I reason that out so if W can't be
one that means W minus one can't be zero
that means this has to be zero we might
as well run it in the correct order okay
does that make sense you see I did it so
if fella has no hard it was a bit weird
to get there you had to think laterally
you couldn't just say oh that's like a
step by step but now you can see how
you can use all the knowledge and skills
you've got to get to a result like that
which is quite vague an obtuse before
you look at it figure out so now
suddenly got a second result okay
these are our two peas in a pod so it's
probably going to be useful to have this
on that sleeve as we haven't done with
this okay so I'm gonna say let's have a
look at this it looks like a bit of a
mess you guys know when you do trig
identities right these there are
basically three categories of three
variables right
you either got you've got two sides
right something equals something now
usually I'm a tree I didn't mean you
usually have like the hot side and a
single side right like one side is some
garbled miss and be like well I guess
I'll take that side I'll start with that
side and I'll like simplify through the
plain superfight use all their donate I
know to get to the other side right now
that's kind of what this looks like
right do you see that this side is
familiar cobbled miss and that's like a
number okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take this side and I'm gonna try
and twist and turn it until I can get to
three so let's just write the
substitution best he's what not when you
see something's times something else in
brackets what's your first instinct
let's expand this guy right so one is
easy enough like that then I've got
negative W so it looks like that
do you agree yeah is that look good I'll
just expand it alright now apparently
all of this W stuff is eventually going
to disappear and it's going to become
numbers of some kind should be a real
valuable now some of them are easier to
see and some are hard to see here's my
first clue see this guy you know what
that's equal to that's a number I've
written it on the board which one is it
it's one that's the whole point of it
being a cube root okay so I'm gonna
replace you I'm just gonna say that guy
is one that's good step by step gave you
a bit the clue before I said hey you
know what this last poem we're gonna be
useful right this guy's probably gonna
be useful
and it's like you can sort of see him
you can sort of see him there
can't you where is he yeah look it's
like there's the W squared there's the W
keep in mind these both have negatives
in front of them um this one doesn't
okay so it suggests that along with the
negative W squared in the Navy of W
there should be a negative one somewhere
in there as well write a manual that
will sort of complete the set
do you agree okay so I don't have one
right now so I'm just going to put one
in one plus one just tell me what that
is
great okay now if I'm going to subtract
1 to get a minus 1 in there is it you
know I can't just subtract 1 because I
want to if I'm gonna subtract 1 I should
also add 1 this is the way completing
square works right so I'm going to I'm
going to subtract 1 which means I'd
better add 1 so this hasn't changed it
do you agree with that but look that's
three and then this this let's just make
it really obvious I've taken out the
factor of negative one do you see the
way I twisted it right babe okay you're
happy with that